Imagine a city where you would be happy to live.
A city that’s not too different from many others.
A place where people live in smaller and bigger communities
they belong to families, circles of friends,
working and school communities, neighbourhoods,
all connected to each other by their regular activities.
These activities, whether they are hobbies
or responsibilities, need energy.
But where does this energy come from?
For supplying this need,
people utilise a wide range of energy sources.
However,
these sources are not always environmentally friendly.
Producing and consuming energy
often results in the emission of carbon dioxide
and other greenhouse gasses.
This has a negative impact on the city’s climate
and consequently, on citizen’s lives.
When we look closer, some households are more efficient
in managing their energy consumption.
Total energy requirements may be different
from household to household, due to many factors
but we all have room for improvement when it comes to
bad practices of excess usage and energy waste.
To limit the impact of climate change, leaders have decided
to take action to try and reduce the emission
of greenhouse gasses.
They have decided to introduce a trading system,
which creates a financial incentive for households
to reduce their emissions.
The system works like this
First, they set a monthly limit, per household,
for the emission of greenhouse gasses,
which will be monitored on a regular basis.
Each household then needs to pay for their emissions
from their monthly carbon emission allowance.
For the sake of simplicity, let’s call these carbon credits.
If one of the households decides
they want to reduce their emissions,
through installing solar panels,
buying more energy efficient appliances,
switching to biomass energy sources,
or other alternative solutions, they might have some
carbon credits remaining at the end of the month.
They can then sell
their remaining carbon credits to households that are
about to exceed the limit and need more.
If a household doesn’t have enough credits
to cover their emissions that month, they would then pay
a special tax, which will be reinvested by the city
to support innovative, eco-friendly solutions,
further reducing the negative impact of the city's emissions.
Over time, carbon credit allowances are reduced,
as more households reduce their emissions
and switch to cleaner energy sources.
Whilst this city is fictional, the system is not.
In 2005, the European Union established
the Emissions Trading System.
Instead of limiting household emissions,
the system limits emissions from the power sector,
manufacturing industries, and airlines,
operating in the EU countries as well as Iceland,
Liechtenstein, and Norway.
To find out more, click the link in the description.